Now to build up the sections
of your master resume.
These are the most commonly used
resume sections we've identified.
A heading, which includes your name,
email, phone number, and
links to any online profiles
including your LinkedIn, GitHub, and
professional Twitter account.
The skills section, which includes
your technical competencies and
your level of expertise.
Use key words that
recruiters are looking for
and give us a sync summary
of what you know how to do.
Projects these are concrete examples
that illustrates your skills.
If they are in GitHub, the app store,
google play, or the web, your potential
future employees can see the work
you've done in a very very literal way.
Relevant experience includes all
work history related to the job
you're pursuing.
It should include details and
accomplishment and achievements.
Education is where you should list
any formal degree certificates and
relevant courses.
Be sure to include your
nano degree credentials.
Awards, publications, presentations,
and interests are extra brownie points.
For example, you'll want to include
your publications for a research job.
If you're applying for sales, you might
mention sales achievements in the past.
But those won't likely matter
as much for an engineering job.
Of course you can include all
of those in your master resume.
You'll be more selective when
devising your targeted resume.
If you're looking to change careers,
a summary statement,
projects, internships,
volunteer experience, and
all the other amazing things you do in
your free time can be huge signifiers
of a genuine interest in
the positions you're looking for.
Have a category not mentioned here?
Add your comments and
questions in the forum.